تتحول الساحه في ايران من بقع مكتظه
بالمتظاهرين الى ميادين موت علنيا
بالرفعات هكذا يريدها النظام الايراني
ليخمد اصوات التظاهرات بحسب منظمه العفو
الدوليه التي وصفت هذا المشهد بالمحاكمه
الصوريه التي تهدف الى ترهيب المحتاجين
اعدم شخصان هذا الشهر محسن شكري ومجيد رضا
رهن ورد وكيلاهما لم يتجاوز عمره 23 ربيعا
واعداد الاعدادات الوشيكه متضاربه ما بين
21 نسبه لبيانه العفو الدوليه وثلاثه
واربعين وفق شبكه سي ان ان الامريكيه
وصولا الى 100 نقلا عن منظمه حقوقيه لكن
اسمين اخرين كانت المحكمه العليا اعلنت
انها قابلت حكم استئنافهما معلله ذلك
بقصور في تحقيقات محمد اقباله وسماء سيدي
ياسين
ثم ما لبث الخبر ساعات حتى تراجعت عن
اقوالها ووافقت على اعدام اقباله مضيفه ان
الاعتراض الذي ورد في ملفه مرفوض من قبل
المحكمه المعنيه التي قالت ان اقبادله
يواجه حكما بالاعدام بسبب مهاجمته افراد
الشرطه بسياره 100 يوم مضت ولم تخفت
التمديدات الغاضبه التي تصاحبها حمله
اعتقالات طالت مالا يقل عن 18,000 من
الغاضبين من النظام ورموزه اما القتله
فتجاوز عددهم ال 470 شخصا في حصيله غير
نهائيا اسراء الصغير العربيه